هذا وقد عبر البيت الابيض في بيان عن
الاستعداد لتقديم كل مساعده مطلوبه لتركيا
مشيرا الى انه سيواصل مراقبه الوضع عن كثب
التنسيق مع حكومه تركيا وكان الرئيس
الامريكي قد قال انه يشعر بحزن عميق بسبب
الخسائر في الارواح والدمار نتيجه الزلزال
في تركيا وسوريا واضاف في تغريده على
حسابه في تويتر انه وجه فريقه لمواصله
مراقبه الوضع عن كثب بالتنسيق مع تركيا
وتقديم كل مساعده مطلوبه
ذكرت وكاله الاناضول نقلا عن مفوض الاتحاد
الاوروبي لاداره الازمات والمساعدات
الانسانيه ينيز لنار كيتش انه عقب الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا فجر اليوم جرى تفعيل اليه
حمايه المدنيين التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي
والتي تعد تركيا من بين المشاركين فيها
واضاف ان مركز التنسيق للتدخل في الحالات
الطارئه التابع للاتحاد الاوروبي بدا
بعمليه التنسيق لارسال فرق انقاذ من جميع
انحاء اوروبا وفي هذا الاطار توجهت فرق
انقاذ من هولندا ورومانيا الى تركيا
للمشاركه في عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
المناطق المتضرره
من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه السويدي ان
بلاده تقدم يد العون لتركيا من خلال
الاتحاد الاوروبي ورئاسه السويد الدوريه
له لتنسيق الدعم بشان الزلزال واعلن وزير
الخارجيه
اليونانياس انه اتصل بنظيره التركي مولود
شاوش اوغلو واعرب عن استعداد بلاده لتقديم
مساعده فوريه في جهود الانقاذ اما
المستشار النفساوي
فاعلن تقديم 30 ملايين يورو كمساعده
لضحايا الزلزال لارسال 80 وارسال 80 جنديا
للمشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ
في سيقي ذاته اعرب الامين العام لحل في
شمال الاطلسي ينسى عن تضامنه الكامل مع
تركيا وقال على تويتر انه على اتصال
بالرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ووزير الخارجيه
مولود شاوش اوغلو وان حلفاء الناتو يحشدون
الدعم الان ونقلت وكاله ريانوفسكي عن
مساعد وزير الصحه الروسي ان وصفه مستعده
لارسال مختصين الى تركيا وسوريا لمساعده
ضحايا الزلزال كما نقلت وكاله رويترز ان
الصين سترسل مساعدات عاجله الى تركيا
واعلنت الخارجيه القطريه انطلاق اولى
رحلات جسر الجوي الذي خصصته قطر الى تركيا
لدعمها في مواجهه كارثه الزلزال كما اعلنت
وزاره الاعلام الكويتيه عن تسيير جسر جوي
الى تركيا لتقديم مساعدات واطقم ط فاشله
واعربت ايران على لسان المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه ناصر كنعاني عن استعدادها
لمساعده الضحايا في كل من تركيا وسوريا
كما اعلن هو زر الخارجيه البريطانيه
ان بلاده ترسل دعما فوريا الى تركيا بما
في ذلك فريق مكون من 76 متخصصا في البحث
والانقاذ كما اعلن عن استعداد لندن لتقديم
المزيد من الدعم للخودات البيضاء في سوريا